okay so the moonlight finale is right
around the corner and with the next week
being a bloody mental marvel one due to
the multiverse of madness i thought i'd
drop off fan theories today for what we
think could end up happening though lots
of the show has been based on the jeff
lemire run they've taken things into
brand new territories with the apparent
death of stephen grant which is the
first thing i want to talk about now in
the comics they have had moments like
this where one side of him has passed
away but like my ex when she sees my
youtube views the guy always comes
crawling back don't let the door hit you
on the way back chump see you chump
now when we look at the conditioned did
we have to very much view it how it's
seen clinically though it's easy to
refer to stephen as being someone that
isn't real for all intents and purposes
he is and he goes way beyond what many
typically tend to class the condition as
steven is as real as you and i but he
happens to inhabit the same body as mark
now he was left behind in duet whilst
mark was transported to the field of
reeds in ancient egypt this was seen as
a paradise in which your souls stayed in
for eternity and you are basically just
just one of my best mates who all think
i'm a laugh you do don't you you'll
think i'm a laugh don't you now to the
best of my knowledge mark has never been
in this in the comics either so we don't
really know how he's gonna get out of it
either however in the source material he
did exist in a realm called the other
void and he managed to escape this by
uniting all his personalities thus it
could be through jake lockley who comes
in and he might manage to take him out
italy the work side by side or the gods
of the afterlife might realize that
jake's heart wasn't weighed from the way
the show's depicting him he's a pretty
bad dude so they'd probably take him out
of there faster than i took my mum on
facebook when she started posting bikini
pics anyway that might not happen but i
do think that jake is definitely going
to show up in the next episode he's
pretty much becoming the mephisto of the
series with us grabbing on to every
single clue that someone else is in the
body it was of course the date that was
organized by someone in episode 1 who's
also the killer in episode 3 and of
course the accent changeup by mock next
we have the sarcophagus at the end of
four and there are potentially other
accent changes in the latest entry a
huge shout out to zero underscore zero
which makes a little face when you write
it out go on write it out on screen yeah
go on you pointed out on our last video
that jake's accent can also be heard
early on in the episode
you're not a doctor
i i feel real i feel like a real doctor
though we didn't get my fist all right
yet we got agatha he who remains kang
and a couple of extra ones i'm
forgetting because it's actually more
rather not that marvel teased stuff and
then don't pay it off i'm not getting
ralph bona vibes from these tidbits but
i am getting a boner over those bikini
picker i can't say that moving on
cut that bit moving on now though i've
been talking about this field of read
stuff i'm not 100 that that's gonna be
how he appears i actually think the way
they'll do it is that harrow will
basically have mark against the ropes at
some point in the final showdown mark
has difficulty killing and no he's done
it before he clearly regrets every death
as he not only remembers them but the
bodies weigh heavily on his soul i'd
love to see it if in the final battle
harrow was raving and ranting about how
weak mark was and how he couldn't kill
him and then we just got to switch in
the personas scene jay come out and
finally kill the villain lots of wtf
moments around that and it would be a
pretty big shock to just drop it in the
finale like that now another possibility
for how mark gets out of the field of
reads will be through layla and also
conscious taraweh was asked in the
episode to relay a message to layla and
she's probably going to be going to get
consciou from the promos on the series
we know that harrow ends up shooting
purple light out the top of the pyramid
of giza this is where konshi was kept
and with layla being there after he shot
mark i think they'll have captured her
and taken her with a group so she is
probably there with him too which gives
her the perfect opportunity to grab the
guard and make a break for it kunchu in
the comics is resurrected mark at
several points and every time the
character has died he's brought him back
to life we also know that the suit
regenerates him as it's been mentioned
in the show and it's the reason why mark
was revived at the temple in episode
five so they could travel back to
alexander and then place the suit on his
corpse which would bring him back to
life and pull mark and potentially
stephen out of the afterlife we know
from the trailers that he'll also be
fighting harrow so i can't see that
being the next step before your boy wins
now if you agree baby hit that thumbs up
button and i'll not mention the dislike
one as i want them sweet sweet likes
also make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss our breakdown of the finale
which will be dropping on wednesday
shabbat now though isaac hasn't
confirmed he's coming back and he's
denied returning to the role i think he
will cause a it's such a cool superhero
and yet the guy is great in it so
message him on every social media
platform every hour of the day until he
agrees to our demands and signs up for
season two going forward i think we have
a lot of potential with the character
and we could either get a midnight sun's
tease or potentially more nods to al
bushmen and the suns are basically a
super group of soups that tackle
supernatural forces and with us getting
played in black knight it makes sense
that the team is coming they're
definitely what i can see marvel doing
at some point and it would make for a
great disney plus show to see them all
come out of the woodwork throughout the
next couple of years as for bushmen we
finally got a name drop for the
character in episode 5 and the pair have
had lots of run-ins over moonlight's
more than 40-year history i was actually
surprised that he wasn't announced as
the villain for the first season but
mohammad diab said he wanted to avoid
including him in the show because of how
similar that he is to killmonger however
come a second season with this build-up
i think it would be great to get him and
he's definitely one of the best
moonlight villains there is he of course
kill layla's father almost killed mark
and there's a lot of things he can do
with the pair teaming up to take out the
guy that brought them both so much
misery now there's also the possibility
that we'll see rauro return if we go off
the comics guy drowned in he should have
row row rode his boat
but now in
in the source material ronald spector
yeah he ended who was roro he ended up
joining the cia much like mark but he
became a villain known as hatchet man
the pair have had several showdowns and
would add so much to see him return this
would tie further in a mark's trauma and
be such a great way to have the
character confront the darkest moment of
his life
i also swear that wasn't a conscious pun
now we of course never saw his body and
beyond that i think we might get the
reveal in the sixth episode that conch
you killed him there was the bird
skeleton on the ground which looked a
lot like an omen that he might have been
involved in the comics it was revealed
that konchu actually had his beady
little eyes on mark ever since he was a
boy and that he caused a lot of his
misery to make him vulnerable conscious
purposely fractured his mind in an
attempt to take over his body and that
would be such a great twist to come out
in the finale now i know you guys keep
telling me off but i even have a feeling
that they will end the series
ambiguously and that you could very much
walk away from it arguing that it's all
in mark's head i don't think they'd ever
now confirm it but if you've seen our
video on all the clues that teased to
the asylum then you'll know there's a
lot of groundwork in the show building
towards the reveal in episode 4. episode
5 made things even more difficult and
you could argue that the entire thing
was just an exercise in harold's office
that the pair were going through after
being sedated there are so many clues to
it from episode 2 even down to the
little waterfall ornament all the way up
to the pamphlet and how harrow walks
stephen throughout his compound it's
also his brother drawing a onefin
goldfish which steven later ends up
having at his home you kind of think it
would be the other way around and that
the goldfish will come first because how
many one thin ones can there be even the
shop owner said how difficult they were
to get now ryan area at screen crush did
point out that harrow's diploma in his
office wasn't signed because mark's mind
hadn't filled in this detail it's a
bloody good observation but i won't
stand for him having one over me so if
it's shown to be completely all in his
mind then i'm pulling an eel on buying
youtube and deleting his channel now i
think we will get something like
inception where there's an object in one
of the final shots that teases towards
it still being in the hospital and that
the internet will continue arguing over
what's real and what isn't lastly is
layla who's come out of this as one of
the stannah characters it is possible
that they're setting up layla to become
the scarlet scarab and there's been a
lot of teases towards this throughout
the series there was the nickname her
father gave her as a child and of course
the thimble that she had on during
episode 4. beyond this though her full
name is laila abdullah al fowley and the
scarlet scarab in the comics is called
abdul fowl he's someone that's fought
against captain america and co and it is
possible that layla might even end up
taking the mantel come the end of the
show now we of course have other disney
series to kind of judge this off and it
might not fully happen because of what
disney and marvel have done before both
eli bradley and joaquin torres were
teased as being potential future heroes
in falcon in the winter soldier and
though we got some nods towards this
they never fully materialized therefore
they might just do the same thing with
layla and have it so we end with them
setting the groundwork for her to become
the scarab but they never out and
outside anyway that's the main theories
for next time and i hope i keep up the
habit of a lifetime and get 90 of them
wrong kind of wasted your time but it's
not all been in vain as you can leave
yours in the comments below we are
running a competition right now giving
away three copies of spider-man noway
home on the 15th of may and all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the theories
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
brighton of episode 5 which will be
linked on screen right now one of our
best videos ever yeah lots of really
good easter eggs and i swear i'm not
lying here i'm i'm not lying so go check
it out over this just don't don't come
back to this video and say i was lying
to you please because other people will
read that if not then thanks for thanks
for sticking through the video and i
hope you enjoy your weekend take care
peace
you